welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka and the guy
that would love to be riding a Harley
I'm not talking about a nice motorbike
cat damn with lockdowns now lifting in
the UK movies can resume filming and we
have a rumored date for when the Batman
will start shooting again throughout
this video we're going to be discussing
this as well as some story beats that
we've been sent by two accounts that
claim to be close to the film this video
is gonna include a breakdown of script
pages which contain a big fight scene as
well as some rumored locations that the
movie will be filming at obviously
there's gonna be heavy spoilers here so
if you want to go into the film as blind
as a bat then I highly recommend that
you turn off now make sure you subscribe
to the channel to never miss an update
on the film and please drop a thumbs up
if you think this channel is the hero
that Gotham deserves without the way and
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our new Batman breakdown okay
so unless you've been living in the
Batcave chances are that you are aware
that all movie production has been
frozen
this isn't some crappy mr. freeze scheme
to ruin the movie industry and due to co
vid we've saw numerous delays to release
states trailers push back and filming
put on hold
however last week it was announced by
British newspaper The Guardian that
movies would be able to resume
production from July and with this it's
finally given us something to put a
smile on that face
according to DC movie news the Batman
will resume filming on the 6th of July
and this means that Matt Reeves in Co
will be picking back up with her shoots
in Scotland in England just before
filming was halted it did look like we
were going to be getting our first look
at the Batmobile tearing up the streets
of Glasgow and this was initially
reported by Scottish newspaper The Daily
Record who said the car would be seen in
the city shortly after this the Batsuit
first look was revealed by reeves before
we learned that the scenes were actually
just for the bat bike I think that
Reeves released this first look of the
suit so that fans would have a cool
video and image in their mind rather
than the one that we got where the Dark
Knight was just falling off a bike which
yeah sums up 2020 now imagine that
have been the first time that we saw the
Batsuit in action not we're thinking
about especially with all the battens
and haters out there already so from
this I think you know the studio is
showing that they're smart and they've
kind of put in place a precedent in
which we'll get a first proper stylized
look at things before they're shown to
the public so that the studio can have
better control over the first looks that
we see not long after the bat bike
scenes we then got the Batmobile reveal
so it makes sense that the next thing we
would see being filmed in public would
be the car in action this was given way
by some images that I was sent which
showed an area being prepped for a
public scene however filming was halted
and we've spent the last four months
poring over every single image we can
find on his side now has anyone managed
to get any good dick pics and I'm not
talking about Robin being on set what
so from this it's probably safe to
assume that when things start up we will
be seeing the Batmobile racing through
the streets of whatever city they choose
to re-imagine is Gotham open areas have
been deemed a lot safer than enclosed
spaces so it makes sense that they would
choose to film outdoors over indoors as
those scenes are gonna require a lot
more testing and regulations now with
filming resuming and production is
starting back up comes a lot more rumors
and leaks on our last video we covered
some information that we'd receive from
an account that was friends with someone
working on the production these leaks
lined up with things I'd heard from
other sources and now all things like
this should be taken with a pinch of
salt
it does seem quite accurate from what
I've heard this account message me again
today with some further details and they
said the following hey death since
filming of the new bat movie is ready to
begin I thought I would share some other
things my friend told me not a lot but
enough there will be a big fight scene
between Batman in a villain in a park on
Halloween night although there's no
confirmation on who the villain is there
was a giant chessboard being built
before filming was shut down the iceberg
lounge is also said to be one of the
locations Batman visits the suffocation
trap from Detective Comics 140 will also
be one of the several traps the Riddler
will set up so firstly we do know that
some of the movie is going to be
during Halloween and this was confirmed
by some pumpkins that were seen as set
decorations when the film was being made
the movie is also supposedly taking
elements from Batman along Halloween so
this does make a lot of sense
as for the chessboard though we haven't
seen any hints of this the idea of
Batman playing mental chess against the
Riddler would provide an app location
for the two to faceoff at and our last
bunch of leaks we talked about how they
were supposedly going to be Riddler
trophies left at the crime scenes and
seeing the almost chessboard like floor
paneling on one of them definitely makes
me think that we could be seeing
something along the lines of this the
message also mentions the iceberg lounge
which I'll get into in in just a bit as
it ties in to the other plot leaks I've
received but bear that in mind that it
comes from one source and it's different
to the one that we'll talk about later
lastly is the mention of the suffocation
trap from Detective Comics issue 140
this was actually released in 1948 and
the issue featured the first appearance
of the Riddler so it does make sense
that Reeves would want to reference it
in some ways not only does this issue
contain elements that pull on the
iconography of a chessboard but it also
features the suffocation trap as
mentioned by the account the Riddler is
known for its dastardly traps and who
knows we may even get a villain that
feels in line with jigsaw from so
similar to how the Arkham games depict
him there's obviously a lot to talk
about from this and if it turns out to
be true then we're in for some big
surprises as I've said I do believe what
this account is saying as they told me a
lot of things that line up with leaks
I've heard from other sources and not
really seen reported on this message
also ties in with some of the apparent
script pages that we've received which
we'll talk about to close out the video
before we get into that though I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the MCU infinity saga box
set to one random subscriber all you
have to do to be one the chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts and
the leaks in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of July and the settle be
shipped out from the interval gets the
price so best of luck that everyone who
takes part okay so finally I got sent
some apparent script pages from an
account that said they've managed to
snap some photographs of their
as they were being pulled from storage
due to filming restarting I've had to
blur the images and won't be showing
them in this video as Warner Brothers
can strike my channel and block this
worldwide for showing things that are
meant for the public it's a bit
difficult to talk about them while still
remaining under fair use but I think I
should be okay just talking about the
general things that happen in the scene
again take this with a pinch of salt as
I can't 100% verify it but the reason
that I decided to report on this is
because it ties in with the leaks on the
iceberg lounge that was mentioned in the
aforementioned message by a different
account the lounges of course the
Penguins main hangout and this scene
involves Batman fighting some of his
goons there's about 8 people that he
goes head-to-head with it's very
reminiscent of the warehouse fight scene
from Batman V Superman in it he uses a
number of gadgets such as the back hall
and batarangs to take down the group he
also just punches some in the face which
it's always a good way to go about man
there's a bigger bodyguard known as Igor
that the Dark Knight has to take down
and from the sounds of it it's very
Arkham inspired it features a mix of the
Caped Crusader diving back and forth
between the people he's fighting as he
takes them out strategically one by one
these pages are quite short and don't
really give away all that much beyond
the kind of action and there will be in
the movie but from the sounds of it it's
gonna be really visceral and it will
show Batman in the way that we want to
see him on screen which is a guy that
just punches people in the face you know
you see a little bit I don't know how
the fight ends as that wasn't detailed
but if Batman is at the iceberg language
then he's probably only there for one
thing and that is of course the penguin
you may just want information or to take
him to the GCPD but whatever it is on
paper it sounds like they're really
going for something special that's full
of gadgets well choreographed fight
moves and Batson is showing that he can
go head to head with the big guys if it
is true then you've got a lot of things
to look forward to and if it's not true
Warner Brothers yeah give this guy a job
they made a really good fake script
that's basically all of the leaks have
received that seem like they have some
way to them and just as a you know sort
of a message on how I receive leaks I
probably get about five emails a week
detailing things that people have heard
but I try not to really
on all of them as you can never verify
them for yourself the reason that I
chose these two leaks is because both
wanted to remain anonymous so I don't
think that interested in Klout and
because the first one gave leaks I had
heard from other sources and the other
one back them up with screenshots and
elements that tied into what the former
had said I'm trying to be the world's
greatest detective out here but again
take this as speculation for now until
we know for definite whether they're
right or wrong also shout outs the
people that sent me them yet much
appreciated and you're the hero that
Gotham needs right now so keep up keep
up the great work
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the leaks and what you take
from them comment below and let us know
and if you missed our last video on the
Batman then definitely check it out
after this we went over the report
discussing how the Joker will be
featuring the film through a cameo role
and who we'd love to see cast as him or
her you know you never know what they're
doing these days now if you want to
support the channel Drummond's let those
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat - so after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the disk or link in
the description below anyway thank you
for staying until the end of the video I
hope you're having a good week
you take care yourself I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
much love
[Music]